are occasions where you need a
completely random number right why not
just find numbers at random in society
why not just pick numbers randomly that
have been generated by civilization
that's how I get my lottery numbers if
you do that
nearly a third of all those numbers will
begin with the numeral one
wow so they're not random wow
this is the famous initial digit problem
interesting by the way even page numbers
even page numbers any any number that
appears in anything we created ever
gotcha close your eyes and randomly pick
one third of those numbers are going to
begin with one so they're not random let
me just say this mathematicians
have way too much time on there
foreign